foreign
let's jump into lucid dreaming yeah
lucid dreaming it used to be a complete
show it's in science you know back in
the 60s and the 70s to suggest that you
could gain control over a normally
non-volutional process only added
insults to the idiotic
nature of this thing called sleep and
Dreaming by itself and now you're
telling me okay we've got these things
called dreams and also you claim to be
able to control them and do whatever you
like in them really I you know show me
some good science but now we have some
Exquisite science and it's not even
debated anymore it's not a charlatan
science
and the first experiments actually come
back to our first topic which was sleep
and sex the first experiments used
orgasm and ejaculation as the test
so with a lucid dreamer when they are
asleep just like you and I when we're
not lucid dreaming they are paralyzed so
they've got no good way to tell you okay
I'm now lucid and they have no way to
tell you what I'm dreaming about and
what's happening except that they do
which is their eyes because one of the
two muscle groups that is spurred from
the voluntary skeletal paralysis of your
muscles are the extraocular muscles that
move your eyes up and down and left and
right and that's why by the way you
still have rapid eye movements during
REM sleep because those muscles are not
inhibited
so we can now generate essentially a
language between me the experimenter and
you the Lucid dreamer which is like a an
ocular Morse code
and you can be telling me using
predefined
eye movement instructions what's going
on so at the moment you become Lucid
you've gone into dream sleep and I can
see that in the next door sleep Control
Center and then all of a sudden I see
based on your eye movement traces that
I'm measuring you do three deliberate
flicks to the left and that's your
signal to me that me the participant I'm
now Lucid okay great now then you're
going to do
two big circular movements to the right
and that's you saying in my dream I'm
now clenching my right hand and then
moving your eyes circular to the left
that's me moving my left hand
and so you can be telling me every time
that you're doing something in your
dream what it is that you're doing which
is just I mean could you imagine who
this and then if you're like if you like
that trick now watch me ejaculate well
that was exactly what they did so then
they said okay you claim to be able to
because
when you control lucid dreaming by the
way the definition is just that you
are aware that you're dreaming as you're
dreaming that's our basic scientific
definition but what most people in the
late public think of as lucid dreaming
it's not just that you know that you're
dreaming you take control of your dreams
and of course if you can control your
dreams one of the things that people
enjoy doing is you know having sex and
having an orgasm all they're gonna do
that's all they're gonna do yeah exactly
orgy everywhere it was the original
Dreamscape pornography you know forget
PornHub you just had to lose a dream
heavier lift but yeah it is but you know
I could argue it's well worth it and so
we've got these experiments now and by
the way we've done Imaging studies that
are less messy for the experimenter to
provide but I should come I should
explain that by the way people would
then say okay I'm now starting to have
sex and I'm now just about to have an
orgasm and then they would say I've just
had my orgasm and you can go into the
room and sure enough with males
especially you've got proof positive
data that what they said was real and
hence you've just scientifically proven
lucid dreaming is it's great we've got
much more sophisticated MRI scanning
methods now and I I won't bore you with
the cities but it's very clear that we
know that lucid dreaming is real the
next question then was how
how do people lucid dream what is the
underlying neural mechanism yeah and
this comes back to the prefrontal cortex
and those dorsal lateral prefrontal
parts of the the brain which are the
volitional control centers which go
offline what we found is that activity
both the electrical activity and also
when you put people in Scanners the
Imaging activity in those regions starts
to ramp back up again as if when you
become lucid
you regain your rational logical control
over the dream state and so the
prefrontal cortex gives you that
capacity to take back what you lost
which is volition
there was a study recently however that
I think did a pretty good job to say
that may not be the case that some of
those are results are confounded by the
method of the analysis and the method of
the recording so I think it's the jury
is still a little bit out but even in
that study they demonstrated that
there's something about their brain
waves that is radically different at
that fulcrum point where they shift from
going from non-lucid dreaming to lucid
dreaming it's not a question of if it's
just how
what is the jury still out on I'm sorry
I missed that so the jury is still out
on this idea that the electrical
bursting brainwave activity is recapit
comes back online over the prefrontal
cortex and what they were finding is
that it's potentially an artifact of the
eye movements that start to happen so
the eye movements when you're moving
those muscles those extra ocular muscles
you move muscles using electrical
impulses and those electrical impulses
that are coming from the eye will also
bleed up into the brain and when you get
all of this frenetic eye movement it
starts to masquerade as if it's the
prefrontal cortex which sits directly
above them as getting re-engaged and
hence when you control for that you
don't see as powerful an argument for
the re-engagement of the prefrontal
cortex what is your personal experience
if any with lucid dreaming unfortunately
I am not a
common Lucid dreamer it's happened
probably about two or three times in my
life
and when it's happened it's immensely
pleasurable have I tried to
curate it develop it and use different
techniques and we can speak about the
current techniques that are out there in
the science I have not chosen to do that
and it's not necessarily because I see
in the science anything to be worried
about
I can Steel Man both sides of that
argument we know that only about 10 to
20 percent of the population are natural
lucid dreamers
and you could argue from an evolutionary
standpoint that lucid dreaming is so
adaptive so beneficial to us Homo
sapiens then the reverse would be true
that mother nature would have heavily
selected it and 80 to 90 of the
population would be lucid dreamers but I
can push back on my own argument because
there's a desperate flaw in that logic
that argument assumes that we've stopped
evolving and we haven't right so maybe
that 10 to 20 percent of natural lucid
dreamers are the Forefront of hominid
Evolution and we don't need to be
worried about AI we need to be worried
about the the lucid dreamers becoming
the next Super race of you know Humanity
so
I wrestle between those two if it's that
volume though that 80 to 90 of people
don't naturally do it at this stage of
after 3.6 million years of of evolution
of homily development my sense is that
do I think that I understand better than
Mother Nature's blueprint exactly what I
should be serving up in my dreams at
night to get all of the benefits of
dreams and by the way we know that
dreaming above and beyond REM sleep
itself serves a number of key different
functions like emotional therapy and
emotional first aid it supports
creativity
and I I've worried myself is it hubris
for me to think that I should then take
the reins and get into the the driver's
cockpit and start steering the vehicle
rather than just allowing whatever
Mother Nature thinks should happen for
me I don't know the only other strike
against lucid dreaming and I don't think
it's a big one and I don't think it's
anything to be worried about when you
survey people and when we've examined
people who claim to be lucid dreamers on
a night after lucid dreaming they
typically report that their sleep is
less restorative and less refreshing
they find it to be perhaps more mentally
fatiguing
but I don't think that's really a big
second night the subsequent night of
sleep no sorry the next morning when
they wake up after the night when they
have had lucid dreaming they find that
it was more fatiguing perhaps because
it's more effortful because you're
engaging the prefrontal cortex
that's one argument but I don't think
that's a particularly good argument to
say that if you are a lucid dreamer you
need to be worried or if you want a
lucid dream you should not engage in
some of the different methods that we've
developed to improve it
I'm curious what the state of the art is
from a scientific perspective because
people may hear the term lucid dreaming
and think that it is a relatively new
construct slash exercise of the human
mind but that's not true at all at least
I mean for thousands of years and you
know Tibetan practices and elsewhere
exactly have been elaborate descriptions
of training and philosophical and
cosmological implications of this type
of sleep engineering let's call it so
what are the predominant methods of or
for inducing Lucidity in these studies
or that you've seen covered in the
literature I'm very curious
yeah right now in terms of the science
we probably have two methods that have
been put out that have some degree of
validity to them although I would say
that when you look at each one of the
papers the statistical robustness in
terms of the reliability of these things
it's not especially High I mean some of
these techniques do gain statistical
significance meaning that when you try
them it does significantly from a
statistical perspective increase your
likelihood of lucid dreaming
the first one is called it's called the
mild method for short but it stands for
the mnemonic induction of lucid dreaming
m-i-l-d method and essentially it's
pretty simple that you create a
conscious and very deliberate intention
to remember that you're dreaming and
usually this is pre-bed that you're
lying there before you go to sleep and
you start repeating this intention I am
going to deliberately remember that I am
dreaming as I am dreaming and you keep
doing that night after night over and
over again and it sounds hokey it sounds
really quite you know science lite light
but the evidence is suggesting it's in
favor I think the other one that's
probably more popular is called the
reality testing method and it's oh gosh
it's it was popularized or at least I
think it was popularized and it's even
liberge no Stephen Laberge was a
fascinating researcher who was working
here in the Bay Area in the 1980s and
90s who probably was really the pioneer
of modern day lucid dreaming and then at
some point he was doing academic you
know really interesting scientific
studies and then he moved away and he
developed his own Lucidity Institute and
sort of was selling CDs to how to do
that and so I think it went off in a
slightly strange Direction and I don't
know what came of him but the reality
testing method actually came to fruition
on many people's Radars with a brilliant
movie called Waking Life by Richard
linklater have you seen this it's great
it is a if people and maybe we can link
to it in the show notes if people
haven't watched it don't worry if you're
not interested in lucid dreaming yes the
movie revolves around lucid dreaming but
the philosophy and the conversations
will blow your mind it is one of my
favorites and the visual treatment of
the movie oh is so clever it's so cool
isn't it genius and maybe we won't oil
for people who haven't seen it but the
idea of the reality testing method is
that during the waking day you start to
test reality in a way that you don't
normally do so let's say that I would
walk over to the table that I'm sitting
next to here and I press my hand down on
the table and the table is resisting my
hand just like the waking laws of
physics would predict or I go over to
the wall and I switch on the light
switch so the lights go on and when I
turn them off do they go off and hence I
understand that I'm probably in
conscious waking reality
and you start doing this throughout your
entire waking day to the point where it
becomes a reflexive habit and then the
hope is that that habit bleeds through
into your dreaming life from your Waking
Life and you start to do the same
reality testing in dreams and then all
of a sudden I press my hand down on the
table and it moves all the way through
the table to the other side and at that
point I think oh The Jig Is up I'm not
awake I'm dreaming and then you gain
lucidity